derrière les scènes du quotidien
l'angoisse sourde mais palpables des
habitants de zaporiggia ils vivent à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de la
centrale nucléaire
occupée par les russes depuis le 4 mars
2022 selon Kiev les forces du Kremlin
aurait placé des objets similaires à des
engins explosifs sur le toit de certains
réacteurs alors Moscou pourrait-il
provoquer délibérément en accident s'il
redoute cette éventualité la plupart des
habitants estiment les Russes capables
de tout nous pensons que tout est
possible il ne faut pas plaisanter nous
ne savons pas à quoi nous attendre de la
part de ces gens qui ont envahi notre
terre ils peuvent avoir n'importe quoi à
l'esprit alors oui nous pensons que la
menace est réelle
un exercice d'évacuation de près de 140
000 personnes a été organisée fin juin
et les autorités expliquent aux
habitants les mesures d'urgence à
prendre en cas de menaces
pas se produit nous fermons toutes les
fenêtres et les portes il n'y a pas
d'issue
ferme on les scotch et on s'éloigne des
fenêtres et de la rue pendant cette
période dangereuse
avant la guerre plus de 700 000
habitants vivaient dans la ville de
zapporigia la centrale est la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'Europe